مواصفات اقل واسعار اعلى جمله مختصره
للجدل المستمر حول قطاع سيارات في
السعوديه حيث تدور الكثير من التساؤلات
حول السيارات ومقارنه مواصفاتها في الدول
الاخرى بعض المغردين اتهم وكلاء السيارات
بالجشع فيما ذهب البعض الاخر الى وصف ما
يحدث من تغيير في المواصفات سرقه قانونيه
مطالبين باعاده النظر في القطاع على جميع
الاصعده وتفعيل الدوره الرقابيه على شركات
السيارات والوكلاء وزير التجاره السعوديه
الدكتور ماجد القصبي كشف قبل اسابيع قليله
ان استيراد سيارات غير مقصور على وكالات
السيارات وان تحديات جائحه كورونا تسببت
في ارتفاع اسعارها
الاستيراد استيراد السيارات
غير مقصور على وكلاء السيارات
يعني الافراد يستطيعوا ان يستوردوا اصحاب
المعارض يستطيع ان يستوردوا كل واحد فينا
يحق له ان يستورد
المشكله بدات من بدايه الجائحه
انه تحديات الجائحه
انتقلت الى المصانع السيارات
فانخفض الانتاج مقابل الطلب مستمر كما هو
بالاضافه الى
التحديات اللي واجهناها في سلاسل
الامدادات من الشحن والانتاج وموضوع
الميكرو تشيبس وكلكم عارفين المشكله
فالتحدي هذا كان كله
عالمي
وحول استيراد سيارات اوضح وزير تجاره
السعودي ان الاولويه خلال الفتره المقبله
ستكون للافراد مع تقليل حصه الوكلاء لكن
في المقابل هناك الكثير من التحديات التي
تواجه الافراد عند استيراد السيارات من
ابرزها الرسوم الجمركيه والضرائب اضافه
الى تحدي ادخالها في خدمات الضمان على
الصيانه لدى الوكلاء داخل السعوديه ومن
التحديات ايضا مشاهدينا تعطل اجراءات
الاستيراد واخذها وقتا اكثر من اللازم ما
سبق يعيدنا الى النقطه الاولى مواصفات
السيارات والتساؤل الابرز هنا هل يحق
للوكلاء التدخل في تغييرها عن مواصفات
الشركه الام ولماذا نجد فارقا كبيرا فيها
من دوله الى اخرى
جدا نتابع مع خبير ومختص السيارات ماجد
الشيخي حياك الله سيد ماجد انت شايف
الواقع عندنا بهذا الشكل يعني المواصفات
عندنا مقارنه بالدول الاخرى المجاوره يعني
اقل والاسعار اعلى بشكل مبالغ فيه
والله شوف طال عمرك اول حاجه كقضيه
مواصفات المواصفات هذه طبعا يختارها
الوكيل المصنع تماما ما له اي علاقه في
المواصفات قبل ما تيجي السياره انتاج جديد
تنزل السوق قبلها بالفتره المصنع يرسل
الوكيل او يرسل ملف كامل يرسل الوكيل تفضل
يا حبيبي يا وكيل انت سواء في السعوديه في
الامارات في الكويت في مصر في سوريا في اي
مكان يناسبك في اي مكان هو عفوا
اختر لي المواصفات كامله اللي تبغاها
الفئات اللي تبغاها المحركات اللي انت
تشوف سوقك انه يبيعها ليش لانه لو بكره
الصباح الوكيل والله او المصنع لو حدد
المواصفات اللي هو
يبغاها وبكره الصباح الوكيل ما باع
السيارات اللي عنده في السوق السعودي مثلا
يقول الوكيل والله شفتها مصنع انت اخترت
مواصفات المواصفات هذه ما تناسب سوقي انا
اعرف عملائي اعرف نوعيتهم اعرف ايش يبغون
فهذا اللي انا نوفره لهم نعم حقيقه في بعض
الوكل عندها للاسف في السوق السعودي
بيلعبوا في المواصفات بشكل جدا جدا كبير
لكن للاسف في ناس بتشتري طالما انه في ناس
بتشتري بس الناس ما تعرف منه
اليوم خالد اليوم
عفوا اليوم انترنت ما شاء الله موجود في
كل بيت اليوم اي واحد اليوم حتى الطفل
الصغير ممكن يفتح جوال ويطلع السيرفر
الفلانيه يطلع مواصفاته في امريكا في
استراليا في اوروبا في كل دوله في كل دوله
في العالم فما حتفرق معاه بالعكس لكن
للاسف في نوعيه ناس عندنا انا عندي بعض
الزمره يا الله يعني يعني معلش لو اقول
لكم والله تضحكون قول لي بعض الوكلاء يعني
يسبوا بعض الاكله بشكل مخيف يا حبيبي اذا
الوكيل ما اوفر لك للسياره تبغى يا اخي في
بديل عنه يعني مو لازم تشتري السياره هذه
الفلانيه والله انا ما ابغى السياره هذه
لا يا حبيبي في سيارات كثيره في الشارع في
المواصفات للوكيل بهذا الشكل يعني يطلب
مواصفات اقل وفي نفس الوقت يرفع السعر
بشكل مبالغ فيها والله شوف يا خالد اقول
لكم على حاجه يمكن كثير انا من زمان في
سوق السيارات واعرف خفايا كثيره الناس
كثير ما تعرفها خلينا نتكلم عن سوق
الخليجي مثلا بعض الاسواق الخليجيه تجي
السيارات مثلا خلينا نتكلم اقول من
اليابان
الوكيل مباشره يجيبها على طول مباشره
يبيعها ما يتحمل لا مستودعات ولا خدمات
لوجستيه ما يتحمل اي تكاليف اضافيه على
السياره جاتوه من اليابان من الميناء على
طول دخلها في سوق في عندنا في الخليج
مشهور طبعا باع السيارات مباشره ما تكلف
عليها اي تكاليف اضافيه حلو فبذلك الاسعار
بعض السيارات في السوق الخليجي نعم ارخص
من السوق السعودي بفارق كبير بعض المرات
بيكون انه في بعض الاكله في الخليج عنده
ستوك عدد كبير من السيارات منبع فبيروحوا
لتجار السعوديه هناك بعض المعارض مثلا
خلينا نتكلم اقول والله مثلا دبي او يعني
السوق الخليجيه بصفه عامه حتى في الكويت
مثلا حصل انه والله في تجار سعوديين راحوا
الكويت والله يقول لك الوكيل في الخليج
بدل انا ما اقصف في سيارات خليني ابيعها
لاي موزع في السعوديه لانه السعوديه ما
شاء الله الله يبارك في بلدنا اكبر سوق
سيارات في منطقه الشرق الاوسط كله فيقول
لك خلينا ندخلها السوق السعودي مثلا بدل
ما اخسر فيها خليني ابيع حتى لو اكسب في
كل سياره 200 ريال ولا 100 ريال في الاخير
في الاول والاخير انا كسبان كوكيل في
الخليج فعشان كذا الناس بتشوف انه في فرق
كبير بين جدا كبير نعم زي ما قلت لك انه
بدل ما يخسر فيها الوكيل في الخليج يدخلها
السوق السعودي ويبيعها او انه والله
الوكيل اللي جابها من هناك مباشره من
الميناء اخذها ودخلها سوق البريمي وباعهم
مباشر
لا لا ما يعتبرغش ليش لان السياره
لا ابدا ابدا بشكل نظامي جدا بالعكس
سيارات انت لو عارف فين مصدر السياره انت
كوكيل عفوا كعميل سعودي ودخلت السياره انت
والله صاحي المعرض انا رحت والله اشتريت
سيارات لكن اتاكد انا من بلد المنشا اتاكد
من كتيب المالك اتاكد من ختم الوكيل اللي
في الخليج عشان لما ادخل انا السياره
السوق السعودي الوكيل في السوق السعودي
يضمنها ما عنده اي مشكله لكن في بعض
السيارات للاسف يعني اقول لكم قصه لو في
وقت اقولكم قصص والله تلحقون سريعا يعني
في واحد من الشباب سمعت عنه اشترى سياره
فاخرا من دبي وجاب السعوديه هنا ماشي شيء
بسيط دخلها السوق السعودي اخذها يمكن بنص
القيمه تخيلوا وجافها عند الوكيل هنا قال
له ما شف السياره 510 قال اتفضل هذه
سيارتك اعمل لها صيانه استغرب فين جبت
السياره هذه قال والله اشتريتها من دبي
تخيلوا السياره بحثوا بحثوا بحثوا لين لقي
اللي باع له السياره التاجر في الامارات
اللي باع
للعميل السعودي السياره اصلا ما قبل
الانتاج تخيل يعني هذا جابها المصنع للسوق
الخليجي عشان يجربونها يسمونها نسميها في
هي مصطلح في سوق السيارات يسموه بروتو
تايم في سوق السيارات عفوا
فالمصنع عمل تجاربه على السياره في السوق
الخليجي في الصيف في الشتاء جرب المكيف
جرب السياره كيف الحفر والمطبات جرب
السياره فيه في كل شيء اخذ السياره على
اساس انها تالف لحد الاشخاص احد الاشخاص
اخذها وباعها لواحد سعودي ودخلها السعوديه
فرحان فيها بنص القيمه لمن جابها السعوديه
هنا انصدم الوكيل وان السياره
ما قبل الانتاج تخيل فترى القصص كثير تعدد
علينا احنا القصص اللي عدت علي انا شخصيا
وسمعت الشباب جاءت سيارات من فئه السيارات
دخلت تسوق السعودي برضه تقريبا بمبلغ جدا
خرافي اشتراها الشباب فرحانين فرحانين
فيها اكتشفوا بعدين ان المواصفاتها
ومواصفات السوق الروسي تخيل غير تماما
للسوق الخليجي طيب ايش الفرق بين
المواصفات وبين الاكسسوارات يمكن في ناس
يلتبس عليهم الامر في فرق بينهم
نعم في فرق كبير جدا الاكسسوارات انت تقدر
تستغني عنها عفوا يعني مثلا لو اقول لك
انا والله وكيل
كوكيل انا اجيب من المصنع والله احط احط
لك شاشه مثلا ثمانيه عيشات لكن لا اقدر
ابدلها باكسسوار بشاشه 12 انش حتكون طبعا
اكيد اجمل افخم مواصفاته افضل لكن حتدفع
عليها مبلغ اكبر عرفت هو هذا الفرق ما
بينها والله انا اجيب سياره شنطه مثلا 17
كستاندر لكن اقدر احط عليها اكسسوارات الى
جنط الى 19 فهي هذه فرق المواصفات طبيعي
طب اليوم انت شايف الواقع اختلف يعني قبل
في ايام الماضيه القليله كانت تنشر بعض
الفيديوهات عن انخفاض اسعار السيارات زي
الكامري وزي غيرها من السيارات هل هذا
صحيح ام انه مازلنا احنا لانه كمان الامر
كان مكان اختلف البعض او الكثير يقول انه
لم يحصل اي اختلاف ما زالت اسعار السيارات
مرتفعه وترتفع كمان
ما قبل الازمه كورونا وما بعد الازمه
شفت صحيح في في بعض التذبذب في بعض
السيارات صح زي الكاميرا مثلا شوف سوق
السيارات الان الفتره الحاليه للاسف اصبح
زي سوق الاسهم او الذهب ما بين طالع ونازل
ليش حسب التوافر فاذا توفرت والله السياره
بكميه كبيره لدى الوكيل مباشره حينزل
سعرها اذا والله للاسف ايوه قلت عند
الوكيل للاسف بعض اصحاب المعارض شديد
حيرفع اسعاره للاسف الشديد هذه النقطه
بوقف عندها وبتطرق لها بشكل كبير انه
حقيقه الارتفاعات الكبيره قاعدين نشوفها
في اسعار سوق السيارات في سوقنا للاسف
السبب فيها بعض اصحاب المعارض حقيقه للاسف
الشديد وزاره تجاره قامت بجولات ولكن
للاسف لا زاد مقصره جدا بشكل كبير جدا
سمعنا قبل يمكن اسبوعين تقريبا في الحدود
هذه قرار جديد انه لا الان وقف يعني كوكيل
لا تعطي اصحاب المعارض الا بعدين الان
الاولويه للعملاء الافراد نعم لكن لازال
في قله في عدد السيارات زي ما قال الوزير
قبل شويه
هذه الاشكاليه كلها اتفضل شكرا جزيلا لك